think i'm gonna have to man spread in
order for brew to be comfortable oh my
god why you're really sitting don't
cancel me you guys
because i'm man spreading did you just
mansplain to me what man's spreading is
i hate those words i was thinking about
like the term body shaming okay like you
just called someone fat like we don't
need a whole new word for it one of the
most overused words
this time of year century is gaslighting
someone does something like a little
nefarious gaslighting
every single time
something ever happens i drop my pen on
the floor i'm gaslighting him no it's
true like or uh maybe i like made a
mistake i'm like the light was yellow no
it was red stop gaslighting me
[Laughter]
like most people are just using it as
like someone lying yeah like maybe i am
lying but i'm still not gaslighting now
but the thing is like you probably are i
think you're guessing me
it's literally like what came first the
chicken or the egg am i guess letting
you or are you guessing we're just
gaslighting each other and that's why
the whole world is toxic yeah